I'm loving the colors today Thanks you
having a what's your inspiration the
brightest thing I could find on the rack
what are we getting you on John's
trailer talk no I just like this thing
officer he told me he wants game now one
thing I love about you Adam is you are
not one to mince words you always tell
us exactly how you really feel so the
fans now have a lot of opinions about
the cross battles and how that all went
down how do you honestly feel about that
part of the competition would you like
to see it come back I like it I hated it
I hope they change it immediately
however however you try things and you
don't always succeed with them that's
part of life and that's part of having a
show that's been around this long you
know figure it out
but no I did not like for the record I
did not like the cross battles at all I
hope they never come back I hope this
moment contributes to them never coming
back I hope we can do that for you Adam
yeah something else this ain't working
yeah baby from LB crew though coming
back so great I thought the performance
of the season because he was just so
just incredible in that moment he was
really it was a special one for him and
him coming back and really like having
your back there in that moment how
committed are you to bringing him all
the way to the finals I'm gonna do what
I can I will do everything that I can to
make sure it happens
now if we are talking purely a numbers
game you know Blake's got the lead here
a scale of one to ten how confident is
he acting as he gloating yeah probably I
would I would not be surprised if you
want but no but neither would anybody
else on the planet Earth
yeah it does I don't care I'm having fun
I like to work with these kids and like
sing and help them learn how to be
better singers and better artists and
whoever wins it's just it just doesn't
matter like at all except that Blake
gloats for you yeah well they glow a
bragging rights like on a completely
selfish level of
but like I don't want to promote that
result necessarily because there's
plenty more you can accomplish you know
if you go home early like and and even
if you win you know I'm saying I think
the playing field is pretty even for all
these guys in the show which isn't the
worst thing by the way I think that's
actually kind of great yeah because then
everyone is in the same position once
the show's over regardless of whether
you win or come in tenth there cares you
know that's how I feel I'm sure they're
gonna love that but it's the truth yeah
that's why we love you like I said
you're always down told about where
we're at we can't like pretend that
something else exists that doesn't like
it's a different thing than it was but
that doesn't mean it's worse it's just
different you know I want to ask you
about song land yes the news is out you
know we've got the Jonas Brothers on
there John Legend on there talk to me a
little bit about it from the artists
perspective and and what you think these
artists are getting out of participating
in the show well you know we all are
either trying to write the perfect song
which you know is the hardest thing on
the planet or find the perfect song and
I think that shedding light on on where
who the songwriter isn't all of this or
additional songwriters you know it's a
really fascinating thing I don't think
people understand what it's like being a
songwriter what they go through how what
their process is how they do it the
process of them like finding an artist
to connect it to you which is something
that was relatively new for me I didn't
really go there until halfway through
our fourth album or something you know
then I started collaborating so once I
started delving into it I realized this
was an amazing world and it's a
beautiful way to show to shed light on
that part of the process that almost
nobody sees let you go Mother's Day
coming up do you have anything planned
on Sunday I don't know what do you do it
for Mother's Day
[Music]
[Applause]